so i have not talked about the aoc miami
trip because quite frankly i find it all
pretty pretty uninteresting
but a bunch of you have asked me to
comment on the coverage of it and i do
think there are a couple of interesting
things there so the back story on this
as i understand it and again i care so
little about it that i'm more interested
in the reaction than the story as i
understand it over the new year's
weekend
democratic congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez and her her partner her
boyfriend her husband i don't know the
guy the guy she's with they went down to
miami i think she has family there
um and she was photographed
eating outdoors without a mask
some right-wing commenters focused on
the fact that she went she escaped
liberal new york and dc
to go to conservative florida
okay not a super interesting analysis i
mean miami is like the most left place
in florida i love miami myself i would
never live in the conservative parts of
florida but i love miami i love the food
i love the weather i love the
diversity of people and and you know
speaking spanish with all the cuban
americans that are down there you know
lots of argentinians
i don't know that it's any big
indictment on conservatism on a
liberalism that you go to miami it's one
of the most liberal places especially
eastern miami-dade county
the other some people focused on
the fact that her partner was wearing
sandals and you could see his feet it
was very very strange and then aoc shot
back a lot of these people that are mad
they actually they actually want to date
me which i thought it was a little bit
weird a little bit pompous and
presumptuous but i just don't really
care about it but a very interesting
thing happened which is that on fox news
reporter charlie gasparino actually said
to be honest with you
the criticism aoc is getting is unfair
and the anchor didn't like it and
started arguing with charlie gasparino
who was just very honest take a look at
this
the entire segment is called rules for
thee not for me by the way and
aoc was eating outside without a mask i
mean that's allowed everywhere i don't
even know what what is unfair about that
well it seems aoc is a-okay with
ditching the mask when in miami at least
she's sitting outside but what does that
mean she's okay what are you talking
about
now there's video of her outside hugging
someone well that was the new york
congresswoman music playing in the
background partying up dropping the
cover while partying at that crowded bar
there in florida critics are calling her
a hypocrite as covid cases spike back in
her home state of new york charlie and
by the way
cases are spiking in florida too it's
not but hospitalizations are up 200
percent like even the whole framing is
crazy but let's get into the meat
saurino joins us now so charlie is it
fair that many are calling her out for
being a hypocrite
while partying it up in florida while
her home state is battling a record
coveted surge
uh
to be honest with you
no
i i yeah it is unfair i i i don't see
why why she can't go to florida and have
a good time i mean i kind of wish i was
nobody said she was here
i i was i was in court
so what exactly is the hypocrisy is it
she wasn't wearing a mask outside
because
basically no one is is it that
she went to a different what is the
hypocrisy exactly um listen it's epoch
it's it's it's a it's a it's a hypocrisy
if she's sitting around talking about
what a bad job desantis is doing the
governor desantis a florida student as
opposed to what a great job uh governor
hochul in new york is doing then it
would be
hypocritical for her to go and party in
the place uh in the center of evil let
me make this simple charlie she's a liar
the anchor does not like that charlie
gasparino is off message here
charlie she's been very supportive of
very strict measures in her home state
to fight the coronavirus pandemic
florida
many democrats have been very critical
of florida that has been more relaxed on
some of those measures she is choosing
to vacation there and live it up without
her mask on and kiss and hug that's
that's the question the hypocrisy being
questioned this
this is a fox news alert i am going to
support aoc on this and here's why she
was outside i mean i don't think she's
unless you could show me you know some
some tweet or some pup some statement
from her saying i think people even
outside when they go jogging when they
eat outside should uh have face mask on
then it's not hypocritical because she's
outside
and and by the way
you can be critical of florida in terms
of its lack of access to testing
because you would like to see
schools take some
if you go to miami and sit outside at a
restaurant
you're not really being hypocritical i
mean
it's just it's
what what was incredible was the degree
to which this was story number one on
fox news i mean look look at some of the
coverage of this alexandria
ocasio-cortez accused of hypocrisy
alexandria ocasio-cortez of hypocrisy
rules for thee but not for me aoc aoc
aoc aoc maybe aoc needs to go back to
the border alexandria ocasio-cortez
alexandria ocasio-cortez alexandria
cortez alexandria ocasio-cortez
alexandria ocasio-cortez alexandria
ocasio-cortez alexandria ocasio-cortez
the heat aoc is getting exactly by the
way this is all within a seven hour
period casio cortez the so-called squad
member furthermore i want to talk about
aoc alexandria ocasio-cortez
republicans were like hot for her body
brian the motley crue song right girl
don't go away man just go away don't
come down here why are you coming down
here aoc says that you just are you just
are sexually frustrated you want to date
her
that you want to date communists so tell
me about that she says they're mad
because
they can't date her
shaun duffy now i do i do admit that
they're mad because they can't date her
it comes off as a little bit arrogant
it's probably true with some of them by
the way it's probably but it's not the
type of thing you're supposed to say so
another fabricated story
um and again i do think charlie
gasparino is right if she was
uh indoors at some big concert with no
mask i think it would be different
but many of us all along have been
saying there should be testing we're
fine with vaccine mandates you should
wear masks and doors
but no one's really getting this
outdoors and sitting outdoors and in
fact going to a warm place and where
it's easier to sit outdoors
seems like a completely coherent thing
to do given that belief i'm not even a
big defender of aoc but this was very
very stupid